folks how we doing welcome to good works
tractors we have a mess to clean up
today you can see all this dead timber
here
kind of in a precarious location all
right you have a a power line going
through on the backside a road on the
front side dead trees in general are not
something i really like to mess with a
lot so i called in the professionals to
have this taken down you may have seen
them doing work in the background in a
previous video and it was essentially a
i get it down safely and i'll handle the
cleanup from there so that's exactly
what they did dropped everything down
now's the time to get it out of the way
and i think for now i'm going to
probably just kind of chuck it off into
the tall stuff here
you know maybe i'll burn it or something
at a future date but most of the stuff
is really
it's really dried out um
not a lot of heft i mean this is you
know one hand lifting this thing up so
there's not a lot of weight here um but
we're just gonna get it out of the way
take it over there for now and then
maybe we'll chop it up and burn it later
on or or do something else with it later
but job number one today is to get it
out of the lawn okay so this is a brush
crusher
bc4215 so you're gonna see bc 4200 on
here
it's pretty simple basically so the 4200
does not have this middle set of teeth
on the top and the bottom
it's just going to have some cross
braces that go in there and take up that
space so basically if you want a 4215
it's just taking out those cross braces
and adding on the center sections of
teeth like you see here so the brush
crusher does not use any other hydraulic
or electrical connections no extra
hydraulics that are required a diverter
or third function nothing like that
nothing electrical you hook it on the
same way you would your bucket or pallet
forks that kind of thing and the way
that this works is this this top jaw is
going to be controlled by the the curl
roll cylinder all right so imagine your
bucket was on here and you roll it to
dump it out or you curl it back to scoop
something up and hold on to it same
thing this top jaw is what moves the
bottom jaw is essentially stationary i
can get it to move here
it's going to be on a hinge point as you
can see and these stops are going to
rest on the bottom side of the loader
had a kubota interrupting us
kubota owners you know
but as you can see you have all these
holes down here for adjustment and if
you reference the manual
you'll see why because every loader's
geometry is a bit different and
i did not adjust this specifically for
this tractor it was set up for another
machine but i've got it set up right now
so that the bottom jaw is fairly
parallel
if you look in the manual you want to
typically set it up so that when you
have a full closure on here you're just
kind of clamping tight against it not
putting unnecessary pressure against
that so there's been a couple random
reviews on youtube amongst all the good
reviews these random bad reviews seem to
get all the attention but i want to go
ahead and just briefly explain why that
happens is if you have
significant clamping force and you're
not paying any attention to what's going
on and where you're just allowing the
tractor cylinder to to really clamp as
hard as it possibly can against that
bottom jaw you're going to create extra
stress around the back of this plate
here and i believe that's what happened
and caused those problems for those
couple of owners there that posted those
videos but
this design has been around for years
and years and years they've sold
tens of thousands of these units here
i've myself have sold over a thousand of
them
with really great feedback really great
results it's not going to have every
it's not going to have all the dynamics
i guess of a traditional hydraulic
grapple where they they lack is if you
want to stack really high or if you want
to load into a dump trailer
and essentially because you can see this
this lower jaw being stationary you
can't just tilt the whole thing down and
let it roll all off but besides that for
what we're doing here kind of just going
along the ground picking things up
moving from point a to point b it's
perfect for that kind of application but
again that limitation is if you want to
stack really high or dump over a high
side dumpster that kind of thing that's
where you're going to struggle with a
design like this and a hydraulic or
maybe even electric grapple like the
work saver mini grapple is a really good
solution for that alrighty folks so now
it's time to get to work i'll show you
how this thing does performs in a real
world scenario with kind of a tangled
mess here let's see if we run into any
snags
[Music]
so
alright folks a couple things going on
in the back side of this tractor and i
guess this tractor in general i've had
this this 2038r for a while um i had it
in at a local hydraulic shop you can see
i've got a hydraulic top link on here my
goal and it still is my goal is to try
to offer hydraulic top links and
eventually side lengths as well
for various compact tractor models
you know with supply chain issues it's
just taking a lot longer than i had
hoped it would do so this is a
custom-made hydraulic top link to fit a
2r series like a 232r 2038r anything
with a similar stroke length um that and
size machine that you have on your
three-point hitch category one so today
we're not really utilizing this
hydraulic top link so much but we do
have it hooked up to our versa bracket
bundle so this is our counterweight
system the versa bracket that you see on
here is category one it's quick hitch
compatible but you can see it fits
directly to a three-point hitch as well
uh any category one doesn't matter if
it's a john deere or a boat or anything
else we have eight 70-pound suitcase
weights on here it's kind of hanging out
weighing that back side there right so
this gives us as much counterweight as
we can possibly have and if you look
really close it's a used tractor but
this did come in with a couple of two
inch spacers that are on there too so
we've widened our footprint a little bit
you know i love wheel spacers borah used
to be our channel sponsor and they are
still a sponsor of ours as well
highly highly regarded in general
they're narrow and they're long with a
higher center of gravity and especially
if you have a cab on there it just
really gets tippy and so adding wheel
spacers even just two inches adds four
inches to the overall width it really
adds more stability in an area where you
need
so
this gives you a good look at uh taking
care of well i guess a tree that would
fall down in your lawn for example and
i want you to pay attention to how i'm
going through and grabbing these logs as
well
it's easy to get those lower tines to
dig down in the ground and i don't
i mean the ground the lawn's messed up
enough as it is i don't want to make it
any worse and rut it up and dig it up
and everything else so trying to take my
time and just kind of almost feather
that lower jaw to get right underneath
the log and then clamp down around it
and so um
there's no need to rush you don't really
want to rush with log work we have you
know stumps that kind of blend in with
all the fallen timber and branches and
everything else
you know there's some stumps on even
areas and ruts over in the kind of the
tall grass area where we're dumping
things out
log work is not a speed
application it's like most things with
the tractor you're just taking your time
you want to get it done safely you don't
want to hurt the tractor it'd be easy
for a stick to come up under the
undercarriage you know if i'm kind of
driving over it it gets wonky splits in
half and both ends go up and one sticks
up underneath the undercarriage
somewhere and and that would end my day
pretty quickly and i've had a good
friend that's had a stick go right up
underneath somewhere into the
transaction i can't remember where but
it was a couple thousand dollar repair
on his john deere i think it was three e
tractor that he had at the time
i know of a couple other folks that have
had issues too so be careful going over
all this debris that's why i'm kind of
one of the other reasons
it's a good idea to go slow i should say
now typically picking up logs another
debris you want to try to center that
load and that doesn't mean it's always
going to be picked up right in the
middle right you have one end of the
tree that's going to be heavier than the
other so your wall looks maybe
off center you know in the grapple jaws
it's it's more about balancing the
weight properly because you don't want
to tip over to the side and
this ground looks fairly level but
there's still inclines here and there
and awkward positions to be in and again
that's why something like the wheel
spacers make sense and having the
counterweight on the back not only makes
sense
to offset what's in the grapple up front
but to also just help keep that center
of gravity down lower and prevent
rollovers and so that's why at times
you'll see me kind of plucking out a log
or two just to separate it from the
others but then dropping it down and
repositioning and grabbing in a
different spot to have that balance load
so there's no chance of a roll over now
luckily our drop point was pretty close
so this whole job just kind of taking
care of all this smaller stuff
only took about 25 minutes you know less
than a half hour and again that's while
filming too which always takes longer
you know and as i was dropping all those
logs over there and kind of stacking
them up it dawned on me that you know
what maybe i'll just leave that stuff
there and use that as some some critter
cover for the rabbits and everything
else it's always good to have some more
hiding spots for them
and it's kind of out of the way behind
the other brush and everything else here
i want to get it away from the road
front and i think it'll fill in nicely
and of course the big cherry on the
other side of the driveway that was just
a joke that's well beyond the
limitations of this tractor we weren't
going to be able to tackle that i'm
gonna have to use the skid steer to
knock that out you know a common
question i'm always asked is what's the
right size brush crusher for me
and this 4215
is the most popular by far that we sell
but that's great for the john deere 1
series the john deere 2 series gender 3
series if you get to a john deere 4
series that's when i say start to
consider that bc 4255 that's going to be
built heavier more steel more support in
there it's a larger loader larger
stresses and everything else that can be
put on and applied to that grapple too
so that's when you want to transition to
that 4255 it doesn't have that center
set of teeth but overall that's the
right decision for the 4 series all
right folks so that is going to wrap it
up for us today i think that gives you a
pretty good look
at what this brush crusher is all about
the operation of it how it actually does
what it does and this is not a new
design this has been around for years
and years and years i i know well over a
decade maybe it's been two decades
they've been selling these things a very
long time and again so this is great for
an application or situation when you
don't have the extra hydraulics on your
tractor or you don't want to go through
that process of adding those on they can
be very costly to do so
it's just one look at things right if
you want to go through that process add
on the hydraulics there's a whole world
of grapples out there for you we've
shown a lot of those in previous videos
as well all over our website too if you
want to get an electric grapple they
have those also so there's there's
different takes on it different views
you just kind of have to prioritize what
you want this is the most simple version
of it as well so it's just easy to hook
up and get to work and i like simple
things it's just less chance of things
to go wrong which if you've watched my
channel
it's hard to avoid those things going
wrong so
keep it simple when i can but anyway the
brush crusher they're going to have it
for john deere quick attach they have
another version for skid steer quick
attach now the skister quick attach i
always like to point out a lot of the
loaders
are going to have brackets for your
stands on skid steer quick attach
equipment and so sometimes
these brackets here these stops will
well it takes more fine tuning so you
adjust this bracket up and down to find
that sweet spot where it's not going to
interfere with those loader parking
stands on there
just pointing that out so you know that
you got to make some more adjustments
there but other than that folks things
went pretty darn smooth for us today
that's always a good day in my book we
got this project done i'm have to come
back through
i think with a rake and uh and cleaned
all this up a landscape rake will
probably be the tool of choice
the downside is i did pack a bunch of
this stuff down into the ground um i
don't think that the thatcher will be
able to dig that out very well it's too
heavy materials also so i think a
landscape break is what i'm gonna have
to use it's gonna cause a little bit of
ground damage but you know a lot of this
damage has already been done but if
you're looking for a tractor tool
whether it's a brush crusher a different
grapple a landscape rake something for
the front end loader or the three-point
hitch we probably sell it and we ship
all over the country too i'd love for
you to give us a shot check out
goodworkstractors.com and if you enjoy
tractor videos well we do all sorts of
those all the time so product overviews
projects track your business stuff you
name it so hit that subscribe button
completely free i want to thank you for
taking time out of your day to stop by
and until next time stay safe we'll see
you soon
that i'm not going to take the vlog
i was going to originally take them in
the back somewhere
they need many places to hide
[Music]
yesterday
she's a daredevil